I'm attempting to go undercover to test
out some of the celebrity cookery
courses that you at home can join one
[ __ ] things up with jean-christophe
Novelli you are golden loves it for
[ __ ] sake so really gonna have to pull
my finger out and sharpen up if I'm
gonna fool my next target Saint Delia at
her dinner party delights course she's
not my biggest fan so if I pull this off
I'm gonna have a lot of fun even G to
the mission who to Cupid how come he's
so [ __ ] expensive today actually at
130 pounds these course is one of the
cheapest are found and caters for 90 yes
at a beloved Norwich City football
ground for that price you get a free our
demonstration of six courses followed by
a three-course dinner
why tasting and a meet and greet with a
legend herself with my track record
being what it is I've enlisted the help
of comedian John Thompson Delia Smith is
more than a cook she's a national
treasure who will attend a course under
the pretense he's filming a new channel
for food show I can't wait to get up
close and personal with Delia but first
I have to sit through a food
demonstration by a colleague Alex Makai
with no sign of her where does he come
in why are you calling me now what we do
folks we're trying something very new
for your approval right we're gonna try
a little Ready Steady Cook Ready Steady
[ __ ] oh please alex is testing this new
element of the course out on Jon before
it's introduced in the new year I've
given Jon a bag full of packaged
ingredients as recommended in Delia's
recent book how to cheat
frozen mashed potato
minced lamb head ting ting two fried
onions great stocking great stocking
filler and happy with all that I think I
can do something all this sure yeah I'm
absolutely short no we're not gonna use
them
oh really yeah I the windup bag I'm
sorry I just
then it's time for a three-course meal
with wine tasting questions ready for
Delia then Kristen alright she's missed
the food but just in time for the booze
Delia arrives for a QA I'd like to ask
if you've got any special suggestions
for green tomatoes because like at this
rate I'll be lucky to get a question in
but I'm keen to guerrilla on a recent
corner-cutting controversy your latest
book who catch eat I hope you don't mind
me asking but do you cheat at all just
for the television yes
no because some of the chefs on
television some of these things like
master chef making everybody in the
country feel cooking is something you
know you can't do so that's the reason I
did that book so it's all master chefs
fault but before I leave I want to get
up close and personal with the woman
herself time for an autograph I was this
close when Novelli nobbled me can I pull
it off this time
Thank You Divya where have you been nice
to see you all that I I'm so close I can
smell her hair what you mean amazing
dude thank you absolutely thank you
happy cooking
you've been this time good you obviously
enjoy cooking back especially new trends
yeah when you've got the time thank you
so much to go thank you
brilliant I did it